hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sleeping dawn I've
got Wade here say hi Wade hey guys and
we're gonna get through this game hey
guys welcome back to sleeping Dom with
Mark what's up dude hi alright so how do
you do this I have no idea but I guess
we just start Gabe and hope for the best
sure okay alright I'm ready see when I
was playing it before it was scary very
much scary yes but I didn't get to a
single switch and I didn't quite
understand the full mechanics of
everything about that I get things I
have learned yes you want to be quiet
around the guys on the walls if they
jumped on you dick there's the shadow
ones you have to shine a flashlight on
that if you shine it enough they die
there's um like gape keeper wizard
looking guys are near the levers if you
see the wizard II guys you're near pal
ever
okay if you see that weird witchy left 4
dead lady throw rocks before she gets
mad and the rocks can distract her right
okay so what thing do you want or do we
all get a thing so we get to each since
there's two of us I've got a rod I've
got the rocks right now alright wait
hang on where are you where'd you go
dude do me a favor real quick bend it
like look straight up okay ah damn it I
was hoping like you were gonna rotate to
the waist like in Bigfoot just like arch
broke it back yeah hopefully they've got
chalking rocks all right I've got
sticking light light and stick art
certain reason not to have the light is
there a reason not to I don't think so
not that I've figured out I've only I've
only run a few rounds over in the garden
JP alright well let's do this for
realsies and hopefully uh after me
excuse me yes you do
is there any reason not to run
um it's good to have stealing but I so
for these big stats you guys I never
really knew what triggered them I
thought was getting close some do some
don't
Oh some of them come after yeah some do
some don't I don't like that about that
that ain't no good you notice we've not
had any turns you have just been
funneling us and directs you oh you know
your choice nice little chalky X down
here uh-huh okay well we got a lot of
archways huh
mark Crouch crouch you stupid idiot a
Crouch annex there he sees Crouch I'm
pressing control the crowd God you look
so stupid when you're crouching the big
dumb idiot it's too dark to whap alright
you wanna go this way alright which way
sniff-sniff with your nose okay thank
you
oh thank you I don't know why you got
creepy Wade this is a very dead end
yeah we should go this okay looks like
this one also dead end
yeah we should go alright cool glad we
closed down this whole Avenue was a trap
yeah it sure was a trap usually implies
that we're gonna die
so are we gonna die I mean these
archways look kind of foreboding so
probably no no just to McDonald's around
the corner don't worry about it right
okay I wasn't gonna think of anything
Hey who door got a [ __ ] with a stick
that's like my main concern the weird
Smeagol ease on the wall I've never seen
the weird Smeagol ease on the wall so we
will minutes already okay should we
start running that is I don't know dead
end
no wait no what is that that's different
I think it's still a dead end I think
it's just a creamy whatever with my
stick nope
okay it's rocks Oh was that you or me
the statues could kill you oh I didn't
see the statue I didn't either I just
heard it fall and I'm
they can kill me I don't know dead-end
desert actually a way to go yeah I think
so this is one more so alright alright
okay man I'm hearing some weird noises
Oh statue okay you run towards it you go
Hey no okay it's a fakie alright I don't
know if it's a fakie I think he's just
sleeping with rocks don't wanna hit up
its the statues what if he was just
being nice Emilio I'm not gonna murder
it I don't buy that for one second that
looks like a dead end
oh god I hear something why I don't know
I think it's one of the Spiegel ease I
don't see it I just died can I wipe it
with a stick yeah I think it's on the
other side of the wall alright okay I'll
trust you on that one
alright this has been a very mostly
linear path alright that what I heard a
skitter scatter good how am I gonna hit
something if I can't see it I have to I
hear that you hear that okay good oh
alright maybe you should have my first
boner yes oh it sure is a reverse boner
I think a reverse boner is a vagina sir
[Music]
chica I can't right now she's nuzzling
my arm - this is very disturbing I don't
think that's true I think she's gotta go
potty
we'll go on a second okay we're just a
little bit just a little bit puppet we
got a wall guy okay okay let's not go
that way if we can avoid it
Oh why'd you go that way get in a way
where did you go I have no
oh my god hey don't don't activate that
guy I didn't I didn't he okay good
he should have looked at me but he did
he didn't it was very bad guard over
there you're just too sneaky for him how
are we gonna we've only got like four
minutes so we're gonna do this I don't
know okay what is this
who are these archways look relatively
important right
was this the exit I don't know is it no
that's a bridge dad an exit has like a
round started [ __ ] we found every
single dead-end every possible dead end
hey okay I got you
you argue walk Hey come into my warp
zone walk town USA where WAMP WAMP oh
you fell backwards this time dick don't
look don't look at its vagina doll I
didn't wait wait I think I see this I
think I see okay look at that anymore
my son is squishy my walk I don't know
SATs are saying there's so many screw
shoes I'm just kind of gonna like sprint
towards anything because who died this
ooh oh it's a wall guy I don't know I
was so scared but I just didn't know
where he was looking so I miss pretender
well you go with such confidence I just
I don't know when to go all right
it moves okay I'm gonna go under I'm
going under move okay I did it
nice I heard something scary-sounding
found a single lever well you know
sometimes you just got to blame yourself
you know a dead end okay and I blame you
or maybe at the last second we're gonna
find everything all at once and that's
that statue yeah I'm not a good statue I
would stay away from that one no it's
fine it's at that point where the
statues are gonna chases this isn't a
dead end yet hated it in what what do we
work with it's impossible I don't know
it's patently impossible how does any
for your method oh I don't think it's
one guy's guy guys guys I don't think
it's one guys my personalities at once
no that was a dead end over there - I
don't know no this way can go left
oh yeah then you didn't mark it stupid
we've run out of time for me to stay
here alright
wait what does nothing happen if it sees
you I think it draws in nearby monsters
okay
wait there's like kind of like a butt
whoa a butt split are you we don't have
any time wait no it's the same never
mind it's all the same something
Oh witch wizard what do I do there's a
lever hang on okay he's gonna come after
us okay I'll go get it did you die yeah
why did you know do we win I can't run I
can't I'm dead I'm so dead uh I'm not
very dead excuse me
he's just putting me under his robe of
the strategy I think for those is one
person has to like lower the guy way
yeah then the other one goes for the
lever and the person floors away is
probably gonna die great if that person
could be raised after the guys locks
away okay
so how would you do that on a single
player I don't know
all right let's let's go again then when
at first you don't succeed succeed
harder I'll do flashlight chalk you do
all the throwy rolls let's roll baby
let's roll all right you're leading the
way but you're also in the back to fin
what
you don't know what this is - going
right off the bat I get a nice red shirt
thank you it's from the monsters well
also is it's what the people on Star
Trek wore when they were like sent down
to the planet to die that's true
we've bet we are dead don't you know
that's all they did
yes that's very dead this looks like a
dead end we don't even need to come back
this way it oh there's a dude right
there where where the wizard guys right
in front whoa hi buddy okay I'll
distract him oh never mind
all right all distract me okay why does
he okay wait no just I'm gonna distract
him on run through the tunnel okay here
here come for me okay he's coming for me
okay
all right i'ma run through the tunnel
yeah that's right that's right come on
come on buddy okay go for it no never
mind he's going for you now keep running
after you get okay good good good good
good good
I don't know if he has a range of losing
yeah
oh yeah he does he lost yeah okay okay
I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming I'm
coming I'm coming okay keep going keep
going keep going oh this isn't a dead
end I got distracted with the rocks yes
your son get rid of them you were such a
champion all right where'd you go did
you go back okay coming around okay go
back this is all dead ends
yeah no yes this is a dead end here that
guy is still wandering trying to find us
okay but that's fine
cuz that bodes well got a letter yeah we
got a lover whoa whoa okay well there's
the same guy here we can run that's the
way we have to go I think okay every
everything else is did we maybe I don't
remember I don't think we've been this
way I'm one left okay Oh behind it stick
guy stick okay Oh stick him stick him oh
no oh good yeah no we been here this is
dead ends we have to go down that way
that the wizard is what this way no
that's where we came from yeah I prom
you're right you're right you're right
okay okay okay okay go
this looks dead end this is very dead
end but this is a dead end we're in
trouble
oh it looked dead end oh crap yeah it's
dead end we're I'm telling I'm telling
you where that wizard came down I pretty
sure I'm pretty sure it's either where
we came from or there was another way to
go past that wizard anyway so this way
he was yeah there's a dude on the wall
up bad you see him creepy yeah I saw him
I think we can avoid him I think
straight looks like a dead end yeah
definitely not dead ends here get in no
it's wait where yeah but the guys on the
wall but we can wipe him come on where
is he oh he's - yeah he left he's also
running away okay dead end dead end okay
these are two dead ends
no left is where we came from Oh Shadow
Man Shadow Man whoa light get lighted a
light of light light oh he's gone whoa
whoa whoa well had you behind your body
oh god he's so he's so fast on you whoa
he is fast yeah
whoa what the hell I'm trying to track
him is he gone
right right all right what does the
flashlight do it kills them eventually
okay well oh okay okay I'll focus on
this guy
I think he know all right
that's where we came from though I think
maybe baby was it yeah that was
definitely we got to go to the lead oh
oh it's all right I'll lure her away I
think she's pretty this rocks
come on oh crap it's all good it's all
good man because she's crying again okay
yeah yeah that's right
keep going
yeah keep going that way all right all
right all right
okay we're good three minutes oof oof
it's been a doozy huh it has there's
another dude over there okay I'll go
this way okay I'll go this way looks
like this is a dead end
wait for this guy to change his vision
before I go this is definitely dead end
okay this Way's got stuff two pads here
I'm going to check left so once you get
past the dude I went left all right okay
three minutes oh yeah miss unmarked yeah
we found one lover right away oh yeah
hopeful
yeah well this game doesn't seem to be
one about hope no it does not we've
hadded
quite the plethora of enemies - oh guy
on the ground yeah Charlie you will get
wept is how you get whacked Wow
there he goes I'm gonna check to the
right all right I'm checking left two
paths dead end dead end and dead end on
both dead ends both dead ends on mine -
okay so we need to go world's can we go
I don't know I've been trying to mark
but I haven't gotten everything he's
dead I don't know if we've been either
of these ways yeah I'll go the other way
wait this one looks dead indeed yeah
wait that in thought no no yeah one
you're wait whoa this whoa whoa
there's a lady at a shadow guy there are
so many enemies right right here is a
thing okay you came behind well I'm
getting him oh wow he died quick ladies
leaving another shadow guy another one
the hell wizard same was Rober wizard
where'd he come from
I don't know he's dead already what the
hell all right well I've been hurt I'm
gonna run for it I guess
yeah keep running he must have been
guarding the other leper though he must
have been tricked by the leper way I'm a
ring around this rosy was he was there
like could there be a level in
in that no I wouldn't think so maybe
let's know it might be the same wizard I
would not be surprised all right well
I'm boned I'm boned I'm bone
I can't run I'm out of stamina I'm dead
well oh that's so hard it is how would
you how would you be able to do that
good God look it's the know-how you can
never have enough time yeah it's gotta
be look we're just luck oh well we tried
we found a few lovers we killed a few
Ben amis and then we got rekt yeah get
killed ourselves maybe we're the enemy
wherever were the enemy invading this
land that's true we are just kind of
like breaking into some one castle
haunted house yeah oh well anyway thanks
for joining me and thank you everybody
for watching and as always we will see
you in the next video
[Music]